it is time for hey tree at male hey tree
at male is when a professional
voice-over artist does interpretive
readings of the hate mail that I get
quick reminder about hey treat male hey
let's face it the only logical response
to guns is more freaking guns Patriot
mail written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because
freedom all right this one combines race
realism anti-semitism and just regular
old insults against me take a look you a
patronizing propagandizing douchebag
please stop making your awful videos
that is the only constructive criticism
I can give you find a new job he'll find
a job it's clear you are a low IQ
individual more sad than anything Jews
are often high IQ but it sounds like it
missed you very naturally I have to say
there's a certain cleverness to it very
naturally working in race and IQ stuff
into the hate reott mail while also
insulting me fight hate reott ism by
using the coupon code hatred for tea
when you sign up for a membership at
join pakman.com the normal membership
rates i find to be extraordinarily
reasonable and a very good value six
dollars a month or sixty for the year if
you want subscribe using the coupon code
hey tree at forty it'll drop the price
40 percent hey tree it's cry when you do
it and you still get 100 percent of the
member benefits it's great stuff